I know death he's got many faces I look
forward to seeing this one
[Music]
hey everybody is Charlie I've got a lot
of questions about the Game of Thrones
trailer scenes that look like stuff is
missing where they digitally removed
things pulling a straight-up Marvel just
misleading you about what's actually
happening in some of these scenes so
we'll break it all down there's a new
round of the book giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video so yes I do
think that there's other stuff happening
in this Arya scene where she's running
through the hallways I think there's
other stuff happening with the Dragons
that they don't want us to know about
before the season starts so we'll go
through the trailer from beginning to
end they're three or four really really
big scenes that I think that they've
either removed stuff from or they just
have an added visual effects too yet
they're giving us incomplete versions of
the scenes working our way down the list
number four Arya Stark hiding inside the
walls of Winterfell looking like she's
terrified breathing really heavy just
trying to be super quiet then making a
run for it like she's trying to get away
from something or some things but as we
see her run into that open room there's
nothing behind her at all there's like a
little shape in the background that's
really dark that's behind her so clearly
she's being chased by something and you
see snow blowing in the windows so it
seems like she's on the upper levels of
Winterfell but I think based on the Arya
narrative that they're weaving with the
voiceover that they give from her scene
where she's talking about meeting death
aka the White Walkers in the night King
and looking down at the dragon glass
that this scene here is clearly from
before the big episode three battle when
they're preparing and this scene here of
her running through the halls is during
the battle when she either loses her
[ __ ] when a bunch of whites breached the
castle or make it up onto the
battlements because we see brilliant
silhouette here hacking away at White's
on top of the battlements like this
actually does kind of look like her
armor here so it just seems like they at
some point make it over the walls it
makes sense that that would happen and
because this really dark shape behind
Arya is really close to the ground it
seems like it could be a white that's
just loping along but it's also possible
that White Walkers are chasing her and
that's why she's so terrified because
the footage is implying a big twist for
arias storyline during the big battle
remember there are a couple big
perspectives that will take like we see
Jon Snow we usually take his perspective
in the big battle episodes but because
there's so many main characters here
during seas
eight will be jumping around from
character to character POV style the way
you would in the books what her footage
implies is that the show has set her out
the last couple of seasons to be this
badass assassin and she can wear faces
she reversed red wedding the phrase at
the twins at the beginning of season
seven what could she possibly be afraid
of she even tells us she looks forward
to it maybe she'll even laugh death in
the face like she's boasting about it
before the battle but maybe when push
comes to shove in the heat of the battle
with a sea of undead whites just pouring
in on them metaphorically staring death
in the face like a white Walker she is
very very afraid turns and runs a little
before she finds her courage again sort
of like a sand well moment back at the
fist of the first men when he stared at
a white Walker in the face and it stared
back at him except this time they won't
pass by they're coming for everyone but
I made the reference to Marvel Avengers
infinity war trailers where they
digitally add things that are fake or
they just give you scenes that aren't in
the movie at all just to mislead you
about what's actually going on remember
what they did with the Hulk during that
movie they set him up previously to be
quote-unquote the strongest Avenger
nothing could stop the Hulk the Hulk is
not afraid of anything than big surprise
twist in the heat of the moment he loses
and then just disappears for the rest of
the battle so it's like giving you this
big badass character like Arya then
surprise twist maybe she's not as badass
as you think in the heat of the moment
but I don't think they would throw her
completely under the bus so I think you
know whatever she is afraid of in the
moment in these scenes here it passes by
quickly and then she gets her [ __ ]
together
my only guess though is that the reason
why you're not seeing White's chasing
her through the walls here or a white
Walker is just because they haven't
added that digitally yet they're just
giving you footage from before they're
done with visual effects because the
season won't air for another month or so
three this scene of Jon running alone
with all the fires around him is
actually probably him charging the White
Walkers outside the castle walls at
Winterfell the way they cut it makes it
seem like he's running with these people
into this door here but I think what's
going on here is it this very battle of
the bastards hardhome tight moment where
you get John's perspective like when
he's being charged down by all the bolts
and horses and it seems like all hope is
lost but he's gonna meet the challenge
anyway even though he might wind up
dying it's like your classic hero shot
as he's charging the villain
which in this case is the whites and the
white walkers there are a lot of people
that are wonder if he's charging the
night king but I don't think you have
enough context there's there's a wide
shot to let you know what else is going
on to let you know what that is well
they'll probably do in the next month or
so while they finish visual effects as
they'll just make the fires behind him a
little bit bigger and digitally add more
people fighting around him because this
is right outside on the feel of the
battle number two I got a lot of
questions about this the scene of the
Dothraki bloodrider 'he's rushing the
battlefield towards the whites and white
walkers does seem like it might have
some dire wolves running amongst them in
the background here some of the legs
seem a little bit shorter than the
horses legs the producers already
confirmed the ghost is going to be in
season 8 episode so it makes sense that
he would fight during the battle but
also if they've confirmed the ghost is
coming back it also would be weird if
Nymeria did not bring her super PAC to
help out there are a couple book clues
because George our Martin told us a long
time ago that he wouldn't create
something like Nymeria super PAC in the
books if he wasn't intending on using it
later just implying that it would be an
asset that they would use against the
army of the white walkers and the whites
towards the end of the story the last
time we saw Nymeria and her super PAC
was when Arya had her little reunion at
the beginning of season 7 if they really
are gonna be a part of the battle it'd
be possible that they show up right
before that starts now we know that
episode 3 is supposed to entirely be
just that battle but that doesn't tell
us exactly how the timeline is because
during hardhome and during battle the
bastards
during those episodes even though
primarily that's what took place during
those episodes
you got the lead-up to the battle the
preparations you got the actual battle
and then you also got the resolution all
in the same episode so we don't know if
episode 3 is just gonna start with them
swinging swords or if it's gonna start
and then they'll have preparations then
the battle happens then you get the
resolution all in the same episode or if
they're all lining up here in the dark
and this is the end of episode 2 so the
win episode 3 picks up they're already
fighting we'll probably get a little
more footage that'll tell us more about
that before the actual season gets here
so we'll just keep tabs on that but I do
think that the direwolves will be
present for that big episode 3 battle in
number 1 this is actually a collection
of a couple different scenes that I
think are all connected people have
asked so many questions about whether or
not Jon Snow would ever ride Ragle is he
gonna write a
dragan they seemed like they were
foreshadowing it during season seven he
has Targaryen blood drogon gave him his
growl of approval the person that
actually creates the sounds that the
dragons makes talked a little bit about
the sound that drogon makes when John
touches him
they said they combined a lot of effects
and it's a lot of large animals like
large cat-like animals purring so it's
almost like the dragons are purring like
cats when Jon Snow touches them
Daenerys named Ragle after Rhaegar
Targaryen her brother Jon Snow's
not-so-secret father so it makes sense
that they would just pay that off the
next logical step would be him actually
being on the dragon so we've been
talking about some of the scenes of the
dragons in the trailer it seems like no
one is riding them look at this scene
here where they're chasing each other
through the canyons that does not seem
like something that the Dragons would do
on their own with all this open sky
around them they do fly in loose
formation when they're following
Daenerys but otherwise their flight
patterns are way less linear they just
gonna sort of fly around in circles when
they're not feeding or when they're not
on the ground sleeping or resting so
early theory this seam here where
they're flying nose to tail through
these canyons is when Jon Snow is maybe
writing Ragle and Daenerys is writing
Drogo and it's either them just having
fun or it's her legit teaching him how
to actually write a dragon and they just
digitally remove Jon Snow and Daenerys
as little tiny CG models from the
Dragons so that it looks like no one is
writing them that also makes you wonder
about some of the other scenes of the
Dragons because there's a lot of the
Dragons in the trailer with nobody
writing them at all which seems a little
bit weird look at the scene of Sansa
watching the Dragons fly over Winterfell
her outfit is a little different than it
is during this other episode one scene
where she's greeting Daenerys and Jon
Snow
she doesn't seem like she's afraid of
them even though she's never seen them
before up close she has a really weird
look on her face this also might be her
watching Jon Snow writing Ragle with
Daenerys and Rokon and her just trying
to process it like what is going on here
you have all those other scenes in the
trailer for shadowing him learning the
truth about his mother Lyanna stark and
rhaegar targaryen bran stark has that
dialogue where he seems like he's
talking to Jon Snow actually telling him
everything that's happened to you all
this craziness all the circumstances of
your birth robert's rebellion has
brought
you where you belong home you even see
him down in the crypts of Winterfell
with Daenerys coming to meet him seeming
like he's at lyanna stark's statue
none of this footage though here tells
you anything about a possible Daenerys
pregnancy
or let you know if Jon Snow will fly
Ragle into battle with the night king in
Viserion because they did tease a
three-way dragon battle happening during
episode 3 yes it will be totally cool if
that happened but remember that Daenerys
can technically command both or all of
the dragons when they were all still
alive to do her bidding in battle you
don't hundred percent have to have Jon
Snow on Ray goes back to get Riggle to
help fight against vissarion and the
night king but think about it this way
when you get this really wide shot of
all their forces lining up on the
battlefield here at night ready to meet
the whites and the white walkers you
don't see Jon Snow anywhere you don't
see Daenerys and you don't see the
Dragons anywhere here so it's possible
that he could start the battle in the
air on drogon then at some point they
get the night king off of the Syrian
onto the ground then you start getting
all those scenes of Jon Snow hitting the
ground to where you see him running
around all this fire so just let me know
in the comments below do you actually
think that like them walking up to the
Dragons here is them getting ready to
start riding the dragons with Sansa
looking at them and then flying through
the canyons together it just seems like
there's too much dragons with nobody on
them for it to be a coincidence you
don't really get a good sense for when
these scenes actually happen in the
timeline of the first couple of episodes
it just seems like most of them happened
before this big battle because we have
about a month to go before episodes
start we'll probably get at least one
more trailer and some more promos before
the season gets here so we'll just look
at footage and see if there's anything
else that they give us where it looks
like they digitally remove things just
to keep spoilers away so post all your
theories about misleading trailer scenes
and what you actually think is going on
in some of these there'll be more Game
of Thrones posting in the next couple of
days leave all your video requests in
the comments below there's something do
you want me to make a video about
congratulations woot see you're the
giveaway winner from my last big video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details click
here for my brand new breakdown of that
season 8 night king in white walkers
preview and click here for all my Game
of Thrones Season 8 trailer Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay
see you guys tonight
you